okay so yeah so I sort of was there
wasn't a title I mean actually raises an
awesome job like making something up and
I wasn't really sure when i was there
talking about so for those of you that
maybe haven't heard of some of the
things i do i work at cognate x i'm a
contributor to closure perhaps you've
tried corelogic which is like prologue
that's foreclosure or you've tried core
match which is like functional pattern
matching except this foreclosure or
closure script I'm the lead maintainer
of closure script which is a dialect of
closure i can buy us a javascript so
yeah so do a lot of stuff I could oh I
also work at home so 0 ms like this
other thing that I work on which is like
functional you I program it by building
a layer over react which is an amazing
library from facebook for doing UI stuff
on the web browser which i highly
recommend checking out and um does is
more radical it takes it takes react and
works on top of it and allows you to
take advantage of persistent data
structures in you eyes which is cool I'm
not gonna talk about any of those things
I'm going to talk about something very
mundane data so if you do list you know
that let's has this nice property that
people often refer to as homo iconic and
that's because the list program is a
valid listing list data structure and
something that you encountered when you
build real systems is that programming
languages don't actually matter that
much because you're usually tying
together completely different systems
right you have to talk to somebody
else's system and who knows what that's
written in Amazon Web Services more you
have different teams working on
different systems internally you know
when I used to work at the New York
Times you know things are written in PHP
and nodejs JavaScript Java Ruby and all
these things have to talk to each other
so there's a cool project
one of my favorite but actually I don't
think gets enough attention is called
transit I'm actually only used one of my
co-workers slides because they're pretty
good but I might at the end focus on
things that I think are cool that I
think people miss I think the transit
got sort of overshadowed by transducers
maybe maybe some of yours raise your
hand if you've heard of transducers okay
so that's a good to good amount of you
so transducers is pretty cool there they
are pretty cool but I think transit is
is even cooler in some respects because
it solves some heart problems when
you're actually building real software
okay let's get started so this is just
you know bridging language barriers to
transit at any point this is like sort
of a kind of an informal talk if there's
if a question just raise your hand it's
fine we can stop there's no need to hold
your questions until the end all right
so transit it says something that we
released I think three months ago now i
think we release in the summer but what
does transit transit is is a format it's
a data format and you're probably we
have an order you're probably thinking
oh my god another data format it's a
horrible idea it might be but I'm going
to try to convince you otherwise and it
even if you have heard of it what I want
to convince you of is that it is
actually extremely useful and if you
spend some time with it I think you will
want to use it so transit is both a
format and it's a set of libraries and
we'll we'll look at one in particular
because I actually worked on transit jas
all right so it's a format for
exchanging values classic problem is how
do you get data from application to
application be yeah yeah yeah we know
about this because you have different
languages I mean the most basic example
of this is the fact that you have some
server-side language you have some
clients head language unless does
anybody here right full stack like
JavaScript anybody well it's a couple of
you hope so too but that's not that many
so almost everyone is probably writing
in some server-side language and must
talk to JavaScript it's just like basic
problem the server what if you're right
on the servers differ from the client to
communicate with the client in some way
different environments so you know
similar to different languages all right
so there are some obvious solutions to
this often what people have done what
you've seen happen is that JSON which
actually was like I mean I think as I
remember when Jason came out Jason was
invented like sort of or discovered by
Douglas Crockford way back in two
thousand and actually people it was a
joke I mean it was a comical joke when I
started doing front end dev in 2005
everybody was doing XML that was just
the only game in town and really Jason
Jason didn't take off until there were
high performance native parsers right
people used it for convenience but it
was only after high performance parses
in C and C++ a ride that people started
using it everywhere because it has a lot
of interesting properties so it's funny
gifs are asking the question why do
people like JSON when they had binary
formats like why do they start writing
servers and services to use JSON I think
there aren't lots of good reasons why
this transition did occur but in any
case you had to have five fast car
search for people to actually take this
stuff seriously so what's one thing
that's awesome about JSON especially if
you had to live through the nightmare of
XML is that you know it's a lot less
verbose right it's a lot easier to read
um because jason has this nice lispy
property right I mean that was the thing
that that Douglas Crockford discovered
was that JavaScript literals really work
really work as a data description format
it really just works and he sort of
restricted it to a very specific set of
JavaScript data literals and you can
basically used to beat you with eval you
would hit the thing and eval and that's
of course a horrible idea and you don't
do that anymore you can use json.parse
but anyways again it's it's it's
self-describing that's what's cool about
JSON i'm sure you guys built json
services could debug it pretty skin a
straightforward way it sounds great
again just to reiterate fast well
understood it's now available everywhere
and
really as json courses are surprisingly
fast much I mean think much better than
even some of the best XML parser these
days okay but there are lots of things
that suck about it so you know we've
spent I mean how do you tell people
you're right JSON services okay so it's
a good chunk of you so things that
sucker like it's a very restricted set
of data you can describe a JSON so I can
six six types right use the only types
that you have that's it done so string
you've only got floats you got boolean
null array an object an object only
supports string keys so you can you can
make anything you want as long as it
looks like this and as you build systems
what often happens is that people start
ending up doing lots of ad hoc things
because JSON so limited so for example
i'm sure many of you have written this
code before right it's a date encoded in
some format as a string which you have
to communicate to your JavaScript
developer this is the format and then
somebody changes it and forgets to tell
everybody that happens with annoying
free level of frequency so this is super
common dates are definitely like one of
these cases where you it's all ad hoc
it's all made up everybody has to know
what's going on you have to communicate
there has to be a communication about
what's the format of the thing and again
fundamentally what was awesome about XML
is an XML had baked in it in its name
extensible markup language right
extensible you can you could extend it
you can have your own own them basic
types and it's not possible to JSON
there's no way to extend JSON because
you're only stuck with what you can
represent in JavaScript I'm actually
surprised that people haven't been like
seriously pissed off about this much
sooner than now the other thing that you
encounter is that JSON is verbose
so it's very common to build a service
and if you can like you know Jason
almost every I parent like for example
amazon web services you can act get it
as xml you can get it as JSON and you're
effectively writing a query to an API
endpoint and that returns you results
and these are encoded into an array in
which you have these records which are
met you know it could as JavaScript
objects and then you're just repeating
data over and over over again because
you have some well-defined set of fields
that each record must have all right
this is super common are you when people
create since we're based on service so
this stuff redundant information so you
know so they're all this stuff you know
basically boils down to you know how do
we how do we when I design a service
communicate to the people at the other
side what they have to do it's almost
always unpleasant like you know like
when I look at like something at like
amazon web service yours wading through
docs about what is what does this string
actually mean right because the string
does not have enough information to
determine this so people i'm doing end
up doing lots of ad hoc stuff so what do
you want so so at cargotec we of course
encountered this problem belong with
everybody else the same problem
everybody has and we decided this is
crazy we just want to fix it and not
only we want to fix it we want to make a
format we want to open source a bunch of
libraries and also make it easy for
people to implement this thing that we
know will have good performance because
there are already high performance sea
bass parsers for this in browsers on the
clock on the server side is it
everything great ready to go we actually
also support message faculty I'll talk
about in a second for people that really
just want a little extra bit of speed
you'll get from a binary encoding so we
also wanted a rich set of types we
wanted what we did to be extensible we
want support for types that we haven't
thought of yet so something that's
really important when you do a data
format and if you have different
environments and the environments are
all
very loosely couple if I pass some
custom piece of data to this service and
that passes it to another service and
then it comes back I want that piece of
data to cook to be uncorrupted right
untouched no one should touch this thing
because just because we didn't know how
to handle it I should still be able to
round trip that value surround trip
abilities extremely important and we
want to be relatively efficient we're
not we're not trying to compete again
when i try to compete with custom binary
protocols we want the reach of JSON
which means we're sort of piggybacking
on JSON but we want to be as close to
the performance of native JSON as
possible and we'll talk about there's
like a whole vast number of tricks that
we use and this is why I actually like
this library because it was kind of a
fun performing stingers those of you
that follow me I'm a bit of a
performance nut okay so ya self at once
so what if you know we build on top of
JSON we ship not just not just the set
of types of JSON has but a whole bunch
of the ones and everybody always uses
things like sets things like binary
blobs things like dates this link types
of those your items the hypermedia all
this stuff we just ship it out of the
box and I'll just it just works and maps
so also maps so not just maps like
JavaScript objects but real maps maps
that support arbitrary keys if I want to
index for example I'm making a video app
and I want to return a map in which the
keys are timestamps that this should be
transparent I should go to do this
without any work which is really painful
to do if you stick with JSON today make
it extensible make it fast and make it
self-describing so transit doesn't talk
about schemas at all and in fact it's
not like it's anti schema it's just
completely orthogonal you can do schemas
but transit doesn't care that's the
separate thing okay so so the coordinate
attacks have actually stood more than
this
you know we're going to strings million
cells float array integers and we're
going to support 64-bit integers because
this is also an extremely common thing
right so those are their drivers for
people so up to what representation can
you represent integers in JavaScript who
knows this and then then it's actually
valid in the spec you can represent you
can represent even though their floats
the spec says you can represent an
integer up to this dimittis sighs so hey
black guys I know right no no no no wait
53 minutes did you been totally
arbitrary totally I'm totally arbitrary
ah and in fact the hilarious thing
happened when I was at the new york
times when I was in the New York Times
Twitter used to set their IDs as
integers right and they cross over
across the 53 bit size and then Twitter
just broke just just completely broke
you would just randomly get some some
random status right so we want the old
it's very common to use 64 bit in in in
application the design of applications
and so we want to be able to represent
those again also coming from a date of
rich language like closure or just more
sensible languages looks like this
includes Java C++ C sharp object to see
all these languages have like real maps
with like complex keys you can do this
but in JavaScript your hands are tied
and this we found to be absurd good
there are no so there's no reference
it's no references Justin you can't
point from an object to some other
object this I mean same as JSON right
I'm sorry so yeah we have we have we
have we have decimal as well we do so
we'll we'll talk about them in a second
so the nice thing the nice thing is like
if you start thinking about what we're
trying to do since we're going to
actually encode this into JSON and again
you can put message back to the side
there and be the same thing with message
back where there's some benefits here
right so a job as a json string is going
to be represented actually as it as a
json string right boolean represented in
the same way no mail represented
basically the same way numbers and so on
so for the what we call the ground types
the types at the bottom the ones that
you're not providing the custom types
you might provide these actually we try
to keep these as as closely map two
adjacent as possible because we don't
want to do any more work than we then we
have to do in fact it's preferable that
we can just say json.parse or done but
we have so up here here's an example of
a arbitrary precision integer so we do
have 64-bit n3 we can also do arbitrary
precision there's some there are some
special delimiter 'he's which we can get
into but basically well actually let's
talk about that in a second but we have
de limiters and so what we do so the
thing is we do use strings and the tilde
is the delimiter that lets us know that
it's a special kind of straight on this
is how we're able to have a larger set
of types is that we use strength but we
have a delimiter character followed by a
single character that would describe
which which thing we're trying to encode
and and again we use these single
character things because we want part
again parsing to be as simple as
possible but this does mean something
and ask if you're thinking about this so
if for example if the tilde appears in a
string where we encode it we have to
escape it so we know that that was
actually originally a real tough time is
part of the format okay so yeah so
here's some answers so this is the other
things you get so we can I showed some
basic stuff but we get tuck you get time
stamps we have you you IDs we have you
our eyes hypermedia links arbitrary
precision and decimals bytes which is
like a binary information character set
list Matthew composite keys and this is
a very closure specific thing but this
is something that also combo most people
will understand we want to be able to
put key words and symbols into our data
structures so we have a first-class
support for keywords on symbols so yeah
I'm here to some more examples so again
the trick is you know tilde character
this is one for your eyes so this is a
this is a more complex thing so we still
the hash set followed by the
representation so this is what's called
a tag thing it's not a simple thing
where it's like we can just parse the
straight this needs to be something
represented some more complex way so
whatever the value is for this
particular tag value this must be a
valid transit thing so you can't you
must define the tag name in terms of
transit values and the supports of a
recursive parsley so you you I es time
soon these are just you know
milliseconds since 1970 we're over all
right you're an extension so you can add
your own good
so as simple as it solicits me right so
right so symbol in list is is often used
to rep like so if I make a thing like
this if I go this is a function so this
is a real function this is syntax but I
could go like this and that's not since
that's nothing it's just it's just it's
just a list with some symbols and some
data structures in it so the symbols are
these characters have been normally the
identifiers in your programming language
is something list their reify right so
industries effing like in Java you can't
get you can't get to see you can't get
it symbols the symbols are part of the
things just it's just it's not reapply
it's not something you can manipulate
that's not true enlist because you're
you have macros and syntactical
transformations are really simple you
need a reified simple type so hopefully
answer your question so in in Java a
symbol of your like I can actually get
this the thing that represents the word
class right I would actually be able to
manipulate it as a piece of data but
that's not really possible okay and so
this is just showing a recursive example
so again so imagine I want I want to
extend transit I want to represent
employee records right and I what I want
to do is I'm programming in Ruby and I
have an employee class I have an
employee class and I want to be able to
go transit in code and I want to get
this which is a tagged value it contains
an array which this could be this could
be the argument that you pass to the
employee constructor on the JavaScript
side and you will take the name it'll
take some time stamp and what I'll get
in javascript is an employee object with
the name field set and the time stamp
set and I don't have to explain to the
JavaScript programmer what to do this
just will construct the right thing and
all the values will get parts and set
correct
so this is about this is about
eliminating any ad hoc or coordination
as long as the server has the handler to
encode employee and the client is the
handler to decode you're good to go you
don't have to explain anything to the
user about how to what they have to do
so the other cool thing we do is we
sorry this is a typo scalar so Transit
is another really awesome thing and that
since we want to send back large
payloads I'm of your results we
automatically cash scalar keys so every
time you encounter a string for example
in a object we will actually replace
them with cash code and this actually
can you know for very large ballads you
can get like 40 percent reduction in the
size of the a JSON that you send so this
is what it looks like so here is a
record so we'll talk about the array
representation a second but this is
actually a map it's a way that's what we
actually encode max as a raise because
it's actually faster the parse we'll
talk about it for myself later this is
the first time you encounter the key
name and the key higher these are key
value pairs will be download but if we
ever account and code that again we're
going to say you cash name when we cash
I and this up as these size of your
payload increases start saving tons of
space so no free lunch so actually as do
to meet so when I started working on
transit jas or transit j/s even though
the trans expect was evolving initially
it was more oriented around just
readability out of the box it's because
of our desire to get reasonable
performance so we could you know so
people be encouraged to adopt it my
default is not about readability it's
just how fast can we parse it in JSON
how fast can we encode and decode but we
actually have a really nice thing
you can actually take any any transit
payload and say you want the verbose am
encoding so it's actually pretty trivial
who here does anybody here use JSON view
in chrome or these json extensions so
they're awesome right because you can
take anything will automatically pretty
print and you'll get you go to collapse
and bob loblaw so I have an experimental
thing work it's just it's just a Chrome
extension I can intercept the transit
payload it decodes it and then reprints
it back out in verbose mode same way as
JSON viewers so this is easy to do so
again it's not it's not human readable
by default but it's just one it's one
little option and book you have a
readable JSON Palin okay so readers and
writers meat entree extensions it again
so this is you have to coordinate on
both sides again if you forget if you
forget you get round tripping for free
but in order to get all the benefits you
have to have the same set of readers and
handling both sides then again reading
and understanding is not an it okay so
this sounds might song cool but it's not
that cool if you don't have a lot of
libraries that I understand this right
if you want people to adopt this thing
you have to ship with the libraries that
let you do this so actually we shipped
over the summer time closure closure
script java the java script works both
in the browser works it under nodejs
Ruby Python open source things include
old camel Erlang Haskell Scala go I
think Objective C so and again the
reason the reason the reason so many
popped up so quickly is because the spec
is just it's just on top of JSON so you
could spend you can literally bang out a
one for your language in probably a
couple days the spec is very
well-defined it's really straightforward
we have a bunch of tests it's easy to
verify implementation and again usually
generate JSON so it's pretty easy to do
and this was also something that we was
a goal so let's let's look at how this
works so
if you want to play on the transit you
can actually when you use JavaScript or
you have note installed it's actually
really easy here I have it this in my
directory and I just did npm install
transit Jas and go like this boom i have
transit i can go i can make a let's make
a writer first so I'm goatee writer
again you don't have we don't have
message Patrick for for transit yet it's
just JSON but you can imagine one day
when message pack performance in
javascript is actually good we would
have this but here we have a writer and
i can write this so first off what says
this is a very subtle point he so but is
that actually a valid JSON value no
value right the only thing that's valid
is an object or inner radiance and then
there's actually it's a bit tricky some
of the limitations don't even allow a
race so when you call stringify that
actually is not something you can send
over the wire you can't send this over
the wire and the second thing is any any
hassle crankier that thing is obviously
a typeerror obviously right it's the
repetition ilysm so it lets you do this
but you can't you can't send this over
the wife hahaha why they call it oh yeah
so imagine i want to send just a number
of the wire and its works so IAM on so
we automatically say it's a quoted thing
in classes loose soil to go to the thing
and this will win it as read on the
other side you'll just get unloaded so
you can send you can send single values
across the wire it just works it's so
funny it's like this sounds like a
simple thing but I've made this mistake
on many occasions you can't act like
this is not this is not valid JSON
that's not valid JSON you can't send
that I think what's what's the real ones
call Jason got really stringy fine I
stand though there's just no thing this
is under Dominic there's nothing I'm
telling you so great well that's why
most people run I'm sorry so okay so
that's cool and i can i can take the
regular stuff i can go w right like this
and then i can get that looks up just
like a whatever json encode an array it
gets a little more interesting if you do
this so like so and this is I was
talking about some apps are encoded in
this way but let's imagine let's imagine
I want to debug this I can always go
well so you should need make it for both
writing and take the payload so awesome
on when you're debugging you'll be like
right there make it verbose writer and
then it'll just it'll just print out the
most readable thing again reason we do
it this way is it look like under v8
just by and it's in the performance is
better everywhere it's better across the
board but under v8 raised parse twice as
fast as objects so it's a 50 / 50
percent performance increase to use
arrays as your as your encoding yeah
I'll bet so I'm like in the previous
thing the fubar right the foo is
wouldn't that be like a symbol so like
okay it's not as a string but how do you
go ah so there are your son sorry so I
should have been a long form I mean
gambar technically this is implicit that
there's quotes quotes around this in
javascript is implicit because this is
this is a string key oh it's just sugar
that i can write it this way okay that
is actually must be a string key okay
like like this is this is not going to
work right if I go like this well coerce
did you know that does that song that's
not right so so let's do this the other
is the other cool thing that we do so
who here knows what es6 is es6 wow this
is great two people so the web people
know so es success is often awesome
thing called map and set so it's like
yes I know it's 2014 sets and maps are
finally coming to JavaScript oh it's
pretty crazy ah but so what we did is
that we actually wanted maps and sets
today we didn't want to wait for the
engines implement them so I actually so
the coolest thing about transit Jas and
this isn't true for the other one so
they don't need to do this because
they're written on top of more sensible
languages but transit actually ships
with es6 and es es 6 compatible maps and
sets and we actually have an extensible
way to talk about equals and hashcode
which are the two operations you need to
extend of maps and sets because you need
evil to describe how does this value
hatch you don't need to worry about this
because all all the values that I
already talked about we already have
hashing inequality to find so everything
out of the box the semantics are already
well defined for that you only have to
do it if for some reason you want some
custom thing but even out of the box
it's just going to work but it's better
for those of you that understand that to
define you quality in fashion but
anyways so we can do this so i can go
tea and go map now here i can make a map
and we basically encode them as a race
right and it's just a data structure or
whatever but this is not and you can
ignore this this does give away some of
the secrets but you notice it had keeps
the array internally and it gets more
sophisticated it becomes a real hashmap
later but this is a real data structure
and it actually is a real numeric key so
I can go and get and this is exactly the
same as es6 right I can actually say
give me the value that's that's encoded
for one but it gets way cooler let go t
map and this again this is not cool if
you if you're already working and
something that's not JavaScript but I
can encode so here I have a murrain
right as that's the key the key is a
composite key and I can say it's worth
and that works because we are you find
hashing inequality for arrays object
strings dates everything so that's
that's built in it's just it's just
standard but this is even cooler I think
so I want to go new date actually let's
do this so we have a date right I can go
equal T map and I go t-bar I go map get
deep so it's a date and so I can encode
that on the wire and give it to somebody
and they can decode that or iterate it
so you can do everything so these things
these things support innovation you can
go for each you can do the es6 give me
the even the iterator all that stuff
works but try it again press the up
arrow key she would begin but that's
because demons are restored in to marry
okay so what happens if we go r-right em
oh right what this is a map so maps
start with the special 22 character
thing there's our first key and there's
there's far but really this is what
matters so if I go if I make a reader
like this I think of our brief are right
em get d this is this is this way this
is way you want I moved to encode that
day I'm going to read the string back
out and this better work Mike I should
really get that date the date that I
saved in a variable right it just works
exactly like lift it actually works so
so we spend a lot of time this was
actually suppose an incredible amount of
time then we spent like I've probably
spent three months on this getting it
right and again we use it we were
building stuff with it and we really
like it and it's quite fast and then
I'll show you a little benchmark here in
a second when you can do you can all
this stuff go ahead I a question when
you have like a reader or writer you
pass in the string JSON is the idea that
you can also income of these things and
other yes so in the future you may be
able to do this that might happen so
we're we're waiting the reason we're
waiting on this the only reason we're
not doing binary is that binary of
parsing strings out of the binary data
it's too slow it's too slow and there
needs to be native support for this so
it turns out the mesfet message back is
actually four to five times slower to
parse in JSON so fingers crossed
hopefully they achieve parity eventually
and then eventually is faster and then
what's great about this is that you
won't have to change your transit code
have to change the readers just to where
you create the readers but all the kobo
just work on you let me by name instead
of this particular library is it like
open to create a performer like for
example so in order to put this stuff on
top of like see oh yeah there's no
there's nothing to stop there's nothing
stopping you from doing that though I
think you'll end up having the most fun
when it's something like message back
urge a song where where the the
semantics of the thing that you're
writing to allows you to do arbitrary
stuff without a schema so right we don't
really don't have like Jason isn't
required schema it's easy to encode to
message pack is like JSON but it's
binary there's no scheme yet to talk
about in order to encode it and that's
nice simple are you playing
nope we're not we're not dimarzio salt
and again people have started doing that
that part of it we're not going to work
on it we sorted this is just the thing
that we ship and we are not going to do
this game a thing but it's not like
you're discouraging people from doing
this gaming thing you can do that if you
want this is not anti schema by any
means right it's just you have to bring
your own thing any any other questions
about this oh yeah so I know what you're
about to ask which is so so if in es6
maps which totally sucks in my opinion
it's a based on object identity so if i
make an object and I change the keys and
I use it in a sin a map or a set then I
can only get back to that value with the
original object right if I try to supply
some other map with the same the same
set of keys the original thing it won't
work so in transit is always based on
whatever the value is of the object was
when you encoded it it's not based on
identity it's based on values so other
questions about this this also has a
solution oh sorry certainly okay I could
show more things but i think i want to
show talk about some other stuff so so
it does really very closely eat in so
Eden it is the that's the closure data
little so it's it's what it's like JSON
but it's which what JSON is JavaScript
Eden is to closure but eden has actually
almost all the proper that we talked
about in terms of extensibility and rich
set of data types and blah blah blah I
would use this yeah because the main
thing you encounter Eden is that there's
no fast Eden parsers like closures is
one of the fastest and it's actually not
that fast it's actually pretty so
anywhere where I would use whatever be
exchanging data where I would have used
Eden I would just use this because it's
the same value propositions like all the
same properties um but I'm not even
kidding when I say 30 times faster it's
30 times faster okay so so we saw a
little bit of what it looks like to use
well let me let me show a little be sure
one more one more thing before you move
on so this I also think is pretty nice
so if I go
so and I can go so there's a set and I
can set that over the wire has the max
and numbers and all this other stuff and
this just works right again this is
based on values but not an identity so I
constructed a new JavaScript outpace I
did that JavaScript the value exists in
the set okay so yeah so hopefully i make
sense came to the fore opportunity
values of Bill foundation mess in fact
and it does trade off the readability
out of the box for efficiency
extensibility that's available for
closure strip close your play script
JavaScript Java Ruby and Python and I
put it I'm going to talk a little bit
about so this is I mean I think people
haven't heard of it it's just so all the
tricks we do to make it perform it so
one thing I talked about was this right
the faculty code everything is raped and
so passionate remember representatives
rate so does anybody know so this is a
trick from closure and actually the
trick if you're doing any
high-performance hashmap of mutation so
what do people actually do for hash
match when you don't have that many
entries when you don't have that many
entries is it exactly that that is the
trick that almost everybody does as for
small hash maps it's you can do as much
benchmarking as you want it'll be faster
to encode it as an array-like you
provide the interface of a map but you
actually have an array underneath it's
faster than doing all the hashing you
can do you can just do a quality checks
into a scan but this actually works out
beautifully for the array encoding so
where we encounter a map all we have to
do is drop the first thing and Raph this
that's all that we have to do so so so
actually in many cases like you'll see
weird things where sometimes in under v8
would be like be slightly faster than
JSON parsing but that doesn't make any
sense because we are constructing keys
and dates and all this stuff so it's the
same logical payload and we can parse
that just slightly faster and hydrate
everything again that's because for
objects you can simply wrap a raise
because the encoding allows us to do
this it doesn't really matter but the
reason to use arrays is that that's the
fast people that's what that's what's
fast and gum strip there's no list in
Java screaming okay so the other
vertical game you can play so there's
another thing that's kind of fun that
that people don't know about the transit
j/s is that we do an even cooler in that
we wait until thirty two entries because
it's very common to in the JavaScript
world to to get like fairly large
objects and after a bunch of testing
with different like JSON services in the
wild we I decided that 32 is a good sort
of set of key value pairs before we
convert into real maps but there's a
cool trick where if you have something
that's like 30 key value pairs in the
thing will actually represent an array
but if you've accessed it more than a
few times like if you have to be more
than a few scans will dynamically
convert it into a real hashmap because
if it's in a hot spot I'll just want to
be trying to change representation but
it's completely transparent you don't
even know this can happen yes your thing
becomes something that's in a hot loop
we convert to ash matter yeah one other
question so like here you're creating a
lot of like I guess transit data types I
guess my visa I guess these data types
are probably
beautiful or they know it is so so they
are not they're not they're not I mean
of course numbers anything that's
immutable in javascript is immutable but
out of the box the maps and sets that we
ship are mutable okay right there
meaningful not only are they computable
but they're cross a beautiful never done
so no the way that we hope the river
that value and set look up is based on
sorry map and set look at this based on
value inequality that is true but the
thing that the map says you get our
beautiful lots so there's a there's
another cool thing is that enclosure
script this is not true include your
script for maps and sets and all these
other things we actually use persistent
data structures so if you're if you're a
consumer of transit from clojurescript
everything is immutable all the mutable
but there's a really an even better
thing which is that so let me let me
just show this bit so who here has heard
of immutable j/s a few okay so I wrote a
blog post which I recommend reading so I
the one of the very first thing they did
with immutable J's came out I was like
there's absolutely so now that transit
exists there's absolutely no reason to
like the first problem you're gonna have
with an immutable JavaScript library is
how do i send that to the client how do
i get that there it doesn't matter if
you have the date of the library you
can't transport it so this this example
actually has code showing that like this
is all the code that we need to decode
to get the immutable J's values so this
is awesome you can write JSON like you
can say chase you can say right this is
JSON but on the other side you can get
back the mutable j/s data structures and
so like down here like after you've
installed these in the handler so I did
I didn't get into it because it's you
know it's a little bit you know requires
a little bit a bit of detail but I
recommend reading this later so we can
go from json directly in
to vector and map and we end it's a
pretty cool in that so immutable j s
actually up tops the transient trick so
if you know closure closure has this
notion of batch updating you can take
immutable value and 01 convert it to
something you can batch update and then
an 01 convert it back so we actually do
this we will Google when we construct
the thing we'll build it as fast as
possible and then we'll convert it back
so it's not just a way to get immutable
jas it's a way to get immutable J's to
your client as fast as possible so we do
the fastest thing okay uh I think wait
maybe do anything else really oh I think
oh yes a little look at this one last
thing and i'll be done so another little
tour that is kind of fun is this thing
that I wrote called transit tour which
is a little interactive JavaScript
application actually let's fire up our
pal chrome to this guy okay so I if you
want to like review all the things are
talking about it wrote a whole tutorial
where it actually goes through every
single step but in a much oh it's
probably slower paced and you can click
and you can see you can click and you
can eat out something and they'll show
you the output so this is also proof
that doesn't work just a note the exact
same thing is working right here in the
browser we ship browse a compatible
version of the thing so here I can go
like these are these are two dates 82
encoded dates and go eval boom I get
JavaScript dates so on but let's skip
down to so this is this is also fun just
just show one more example I want I want
to include a point so
in JavaScript just functions whatever
but I want to echo for two points on the
wire this is a tag value right where the
representation is encoded as an array I
can click like this so I can cycle I
want to represent geometry it can do
this naturally by providing custom
handlers so this is what corresponds
this tag corresponds to a hamlet it's a
map of handling and it will invoke this
function when it encounters late same
for right handlers so this is the right
side so here when we get a point you can
basically say using the handlers and it
allows us to go from constructor to hand
would we write it out we say what's the
tag return point representation on the
wires are raised to return to reign of
the field on the most rare condition for
this matter and then you should see I
should be able to encode an array of a
point that's it and so it's actually
very it's very succinct to write
handlers for all the types that you care
about let's just see caching so just
real quick again so here is uh obviously
an array of objects where you have a
ridiculous number of redundant
information it's absurd right just
repeating all this stuff so this is this
is simply showing the size of the
transiting strain versus the JSON string
so this is with these things collapsed
into their cached version it looks like
this right so the first time you see
user ID you get this the second time you
replace it with the cash clip so let's
see how this plays out and its name is
real so this is an 89 k JSON j something
so there's two things i'm showing it one
is without caching so that's how big the
JSON payload would be without caching
this update is with transits caching so
just to make sure that this is not the
same so in this
we parse were just parsing JSON this
transit read actually constructed
keywords and all these custom data
structures so it's really not actually
doing the same thing so how long does it
take so this should be pretty shocking
hey this is json.parse we know that
transient must do way more work like to
hundreds of a millisecond slower it's
not the stock in the matter the
performance is not quite as good in
Safari Firefox well again we've built
lots of applications the difference is
not is like basically negligible and if
you actually did all the work of going
through and hydrating everything it
would be horrible your performance would
not be that good so here for example is
like JSON actually has you can provide a
hydrate function and that and this is
not doing any work it's already a huge
perfect to even install hydrate so our
approach is just again it allows us to
get the expressivity but we are not
losing on perfect it's the third
benchmark oh so this is fine so this is
showing this is this is the benefit of
encoding everything as arrays and cash
with all the cash because the feeling is
smaller and it's a raise so this panel
is a netting is just json.parse this is
judge gets on parts just on the tram to
chase something so this parts is in in
this amount of time so it only takes
like point yes I say a 10-0 times it's
all gasp
exactly only six types of a millisecond
took after parsec yeah to know so that's
what that's so that's why these never
shoot impress you because we actually
called parse and then recursively
descend into the whole thing yeah yeah
so parse is the very first thing that
happens so that's it well hopefully I'll
get these flights up somewhere there's
lots of there's lots of there's a Google
Group there's the original blog post
there's all these implementations
they're all fun to use on their suspect
so if you're like I want to implement
this in common list for skiing you can
just follow the spec and do that yeah
no no so you can compute so it's
arbitrary we don't invoke the
constructor for you that might not have
been clearer so you can do that in
vacation yourself so so because if we
can't guess we can't know what that's
going to be so the handlers are again
that's the trade-off you have to write
the handlers and those that will have to
be written the encoder when your server
side language and the decoder in the
host language on the climate that what
has to be done no no no no no so we
don't again we don't invoke the
constructor so that means it's when
you do when you do it it will you suck
you touch things yes so for me there's
lots of cool things like something that
I thought you know that I've always want
to do is like to be awesome to represent
for example RGB values on the wire
that's like some man be really cool
another one is like for anybody doing
geospatial stuff like if you look at
these libraries it's so crazy like geo
Jason is the big thing but you have to
like use geo JSON and it does everything
for you and you have to use the library
but there are so many other domains that
would really benefit from shared on
domain know like shave domain
representation that's why people did geo
JSON is they want we should have one
domain representation that any library
can build off up but it kind of sucks
because that's at a walled garden and
the idea of trans is that this is just
too beneficial so if we have shared
domains we can talk about them and we
can just it just works right we be using
no you can you know I don't know so see
you if you wanted to sell it handle you
want to use a completely different
presentation for maps if you want I want
ray maps like you know ray great race
next you know you can do that there's no
there's nothing stopping you from doing
this stuff no kyojin it would have been
overkill on the beautiful thing about
this is that when you construct that
thing that custom thing you want to
construct the piece of data that you're
going to get is already completely
hydrated right it's already ready to go
you just have to construct your fav
person you don't if you don't to descend
but personally into that thing at all
you know right right I think back there
there's no no no like a limp like a
linter for the format oh no no no it's
just that's the thing because we don't
you don't you don't write it by hand so
jason has this thing where you write it
by hand right you really do write it by
hand we're here what we want to do is
you're like no way no we're not going to
write this stuff by hand you can if you
want and if it will it will work but
usually what happens is that on the
server side you've constructed some
graph of your objects and you're calling
json.stringify you're not writing data
literals because you read it out of a
database you know
no no no so we definitely right do not
recommend using it as a persistent thing
no you should not use this is for the
persistent thanks yeah I mean no it's
it's hilarious because like you bet you
bring that up in the very like the
second line or something is like do not
use this as a persistent format on disk
you should not do that because yes we
may very well make change the details of
what's the actual representation on the
wire is but yeah good point there did
you ever imagine being able to send
decoders over the wire no because he has
ascending arbitrate computations I mean
that's just can of worms but it's very
little work and we've actually again
we're building systems and you know for
us what's great is that you mean it's a
massive set of types that you go to the
box and foremost data rate applications
um the set of types of we ship are good
enough in fact I like initially when it
came out people wanted to like use it as
like objects you're like actual object
serialization and I'm like you can do
that but it's kind of abusing the sort
of data centric approach that we tend to
adopt at least in the the closure world
to find it some instructors s as you
need as we need time to be out
like define types on the fly to install
handles on the fly
we have support for doing that type of
thing yeah may I think I know what
you're saying thank you so you brought a
few types but but that's why I just said
you can always extend it I mean that was
those points and examples of points and
stuff those aren't built in hey no no
the whole the whole the whole value
proposition is that I have you have our
15 and you have hundreds you can you
could bring all those to the system all
right I'm sorry no my blog is not on
this list of resources but but it's
pretty easy my handle on Twitter's like
Swan Odette it's just wanna get github
IL ya just getting back to the
persistent um what would you use the
reason I'm asking is one of the many
uses situation is as a persistent yeah
configurations things like the
package.json so so so what I try to
throw out there is like the funny thing
about this right is if you really want
to persistent data format it generally
um the host languages usually as a good
serialization story so enclosure transit
is not a thing it's just it's just a
library that we use on disk restore
eating because even as a stable thing
we're just going to save it save that we
read it and then I want to send it to a
closure strip client and then I go
transit right and I go transit read but
that what we stored on this with some
other format that's better for that and
that I that is fine do whatever whatever
the host if you want to be like I want
to go from yellow to something else you
can you know whatever and I think most
people are doing that they have some
other thing that they that's more
natural for the language they're really
using transit justice conveyance so
transits really not about like data on
disk it's just like how do we get the
same semantic value from point
point B to Point C it's for transient
exactly right no so the single letter
type sweet because it's basically a
small set of characters I know those are
reserves there's a reserve you have to
use tags so it's tilt a hash in some
arbitrary strain and you can provide
what something that came up that I think
would be great and it still hasn't
happened as again like for example I
would love to see people like start
defining like and the same way that geo
Jason business like you know geo / point
like that's a string and everybody
disagrees on what that means
semantically of course anybody can
implement the constructors for those
what everywhere they want I think with
huge to like hat a series of standard
tags for the types of data that people
want to share I think would be awesome
like RGB /x RGB / whatever you know RGB
slat our color color / x or color / RGB
color / rgba like there's a lot of fun
things you can do and I actually suspect
that people are doing them already in
like their applications but it would be
cool to see people start sharing their
there you know are the types of the care
about is there any place for their
libraries in the beginning again people
started talking about this I think again
what happened was like I think was a bit
unfortunate like it was like transit
came out people were just like
scratching their heads and just slowly
starting to get it which is why I talked
about today I think people should
revisit it but then transducers came out
right right there after I don't like you
will just forgot about transit but yes
actually somebody actually contacted us
pretty early on they want to like
collect schemas I think it's a great i
think it's an awesome idea but nobody's
actually you know that's idea as a
resurfaced yet
what do you mean by that
oh no people are already doing this so
so sort of trance so people are already
doing yeah people already do this thing
which is that so we actually have the
content-type it's I believe its
application / trans out + jate transit
plus JSON so so it's I mean the thing
people offered we're saying like oh this
is so crazy like no it wasn't like I
worked in rails for like four years in
real sense it's really nice pattern you
define a resource and you say you're
going to return HTML or JSON and you
just for X amount and you just call the
right encoder for all these refs right
Yousef have a new one called you know
transit and the boom you're you're in
point is transit ready and whoever wants
to consume it can so is it actually
providing a transit services like it
should it's like almost trivial right
you just have to include transit in just
encoding are you planning to all
registered an idea oh we should do that
I don't know if there's a miss any of
the next yeah yeah I don't think we've
done that yet but that's a great idea
and yeah no no that's yep good thing to
work on I think we were you know a lot
of it's just we want more people to use
it I mean after the other thing is like
we're using it and it fits our needs but
I think a lot of it's like you know what
else are we missing like something that
something that I would like something
that came up it was like yeah it's an
amazing idea so right now data formats
for example don't have a good way to
talk about metadata and that's something
that would be awesome this is why we
haven't like said this is exactly the
representation a metadata is really cool
if you're used to closure where you can
put metadata on anything yeah it's
really powerful it'll be awesome to have
that as part of the specification like I
can say this thing has metadata I don't
affect its value or the Equality
semantics but I can read that out right
and that would be super cool and it'd be
great with the data formats supported it
but it doesn't it doesn't yet but again
we need people to use it to say i love
transit I really want metadata now yeah
right you can't describe the data again
you can't you can't you can't put these
side properties you can't describe that
part of it's just data um again it's
something to my experience is that
number one transit it eliminates all
these problems and once those problems
disappear you start thinking I want now
that that I see what it gives me there
are other things that I want but it
really requires people to use it
understand its limitations and start
getting you know on the google group and
start saying this is this is really
great we want to we want to push it
further I'm just so curious ceza that
it's got key words and symbols uh-huh
since JavaScript doesn't really have
those at all so we use them just because
we need to use them because closure data
has them but we don't want to we don't
want to lose information by becoming a
string and actually there's a huge perf
win for so something that's that's
surprising is for example if you use
closure script parsing leave the
ridiculously huge representation of
showing those like 83 k or 87 k it's
it's still even enclosure script it's as
fast to do the transit read even though
we're constructing a graph of immutable
objects but this is because we have
keywords and then caching is even better
if you have keywords is what we can do
when we do the read we ask to have an
object cache so if we encounter a cash
code we don't feel construct a new
object so when you read this massive
thing with thousands of records all the
keys are shared they're all the same
object in memory yes so so this is like
a benefit from actually having that as a
separate type versus it straight does it
make it does that make sense yeah I
guess
no but it's a close to close your thing
it's a very much a closure to the
specific thing yeah so if you set a real
key look JavaScript programmers will
never do that they just want but if you
were enclosure script you would send our
meal keyword so actually I can make a
real quick but it's an interesting yeah
but so nobody uses keywords but like
look so here's oh my god I mean nobody
from JavaScript uses keywords but we do
but for example you could go you can
make a keyword like this so you would
never use this thing but then if I go
team app when I go keyword and then I go
w right and so panicky word was a key
word was a keyword object and we we
included in a special way again take
that big for purpose it's for closure
script engine enclosure and we don't
want this is us and that's so specific
to closure we don't expect people to
actually construct keywords in
JavaScript so we don't because with the
thing that you're running to actually
imagine Ruby people would be like oh I
can use keywords but you know the
problems that everybody gave up you know
they did everybody gave up edgewood's
like i should i convert keywords back in
the strings and you can round trip up so
and we're saying no if you actually in
Ruby went from keyword to keyword and
you sent it over the wire with transit
yes you would get a keyword back I would
always be the same like you keep like a
no so we can't do in turning because so
we we would love to do in turning like
if there was a share you were a few
words might be useful and jobs because
then you can say this is sidekick this
is a thing of what I have in turn so
he's not my dad and I always never seen
this out yeah so we would love to do in
turning but actually it's so it requires
week maps and weak maps are another
thing that's in es6 but weak maps are
not what you call Polly syllable I mean
it requires interview so in JavaScript
what people often do they say here's
some type that I said we'll drive in the
future and I can provide a simulation of
that type but the problem week map is it
requires integration with the garbage
collector for it to work you can't
implement it in usual and it must be
exactly so so we can't do it because so
that's why you gotta know that's what we
haven't done it because there's no
there's no way for us cuz that would be
useful otherwise he might redeem strings
oh no we would love to do if we could do
in turning it would be awesome but we
can so I think probably spoken long
enough thank you thanks a million